really is time to leave the anger
and bitter politics of division behind
us it's time for us to come together as
a nation to heal
i will be president for all americans
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
this is the time to heal in america
joe biden promised unity but his own
staff already stepping on that message
incoming white house deputy chief of
staff jen o'malley dillon
trash talking gop lawmakers with this
attack
quote the president-elect was able to
connect with people over this sense of
unity
in the primary people would mock them
like you think you can work with
republicans
i'm not saying they're not a bunch of
expletives
mitch mcconnell's terrible but this
sense that you couldn't
wish for that you couldn't wish for this
bipartisan ideal
he rejected that and after the backlash
i'm ali dillon now walking back those
comments and saying she used some words
that she probably could have chosen
better
all right dana uh tell me why after
four years of what we've just been
through why i should get
so upset with this type of partisan
language
yeah i don't think that's going to rise
to the level of being upset i really
want to meet jen o'malley dylan i think
that she's
had a very impressive career i'd like to
talk to her about it she doesn't do a
lot of media interviews and i think
there was only one profile of her
done during the entire campaign and
the thing is that remember we talked
about women's magazines
they're not coming to do profiles of
republican lawmakers or
republican staffers and i'm sure she
felt very comfortable talking to glamour
magazine and that's great that's fine
the thing is that her boss is trying to
project an image of unity
and if you undercut that by using some
language like
you know that word about lawmakers
then that's going to make the headline
it's fine you can say it but those are
the headlines
that's that's what's going to end up
happening or like joe biden the other
night he
does this speech in prime time after the
electoral college certified the vote
and while he talked about unity he also
talked about abuse of power and was
quite dismissive of donald trump now you
can do that
but if you expect the headlines to be
different if you
are saying things like that then you're
wrong and
biden has a pretty thin skin
when it comes to media coverage so i
think we should
buckle up there's going to be some more
of this choice language out there
greg i guess the point is dana's point
is this is that it was about the
messaging not necessarily the message
well the only reason why dana wants to
meet her is because they're both
potty mouths she makes dana look like uh
like a
like well anyway um when a democrat
refers to you as an
effort that's a compliment because that
means you're a fighter
but but the but the bigger the bigger
message here is
if you remember the debate and where
kamala harris
said that biden was racist which he said
i was that little girl
that was kamala's big moment and then
when colbert
asked her about that that she had
inferred that biden was racist she said
it's a debate and she laughed and the
message was
we don't really believe what we're
saying
it's all for show it's all to win and so
um i start thinking about that when
biden
starts talking about uh this need for
unity
and i keep going back to but he called
you know all the trump supporters
unsalvageable bigots he had nazi uh
of imagery in his in his campaign
commercials
so we to believe that all of that all of
those racial accusations were also all
for show
it was just to win an election and
that's kind of scary to think
that all of this race-baiting stick from
the left
that we've had to endure for years is
completely baseless we're they just
they're they're willing to create
violence
and riots just to win an election that's
pretty scary
would you like to react to that
well i wouldn't even know where to begin
we just had you know some of the proud
boys and those people on the streets
here in washington
last week and it was i mean they're
attacking black churches i don't even
know where to begin with that when i
just say this
i think what's most important in terms
of what we heard was that
i think in the full context she's saying
that president-elect biden wants to work
with republicans no matter what some on
the left may say in terms of
how they think republicans have behaved
in terms of the politics
and i think that biden's been very clear
that the tenor of his
administration will be one in which he
works with people who did not
did not vote for him so again i think
that's the important thing that by the
way
the idea that republicans would be on
the fainting couch
because of profanity my goodness the
last four years of trump
i mean it's unbelievable i don't hear
anybody going on about
what about people racism people say oh
people say go back to where you came
from and talking about all that
i mean that's just
no they weren't there was one and you
know what i mean it seems to me
you see you get you get trump saying all
these things he said worst things this
week about mitch mcconnell because
mcconnell said biden is president okay
juan
what about ism uh dagan feel free to
call me a fornicator
or a sub right just do it to my face i
much prefer somebody to come at me head
on
and try and stab me in the chest then
somebody who says
oh come over here let me give you a big
hug and then they try to
shank me in the kidney because that's
what's going on here
that unity that unity message it is a
crumbly
stack of cow chips what she said about
mitch mcconnell
oh he's terrible you know who prevented
debate
on two different stimulus packages in
the senate the
democrats who cares about the american
people
not them
yeah and she shouldn't have apologized
because she didn't mean it
no i of all people can tell when an
apology is sincere
and that was not a sincere apology
coming up